let's go in I everybody welcome to part
seven of our Python with ltk for natural
language processing tutorial video
series in this video we're gonna be
talking about named entity recognition
with Python as Python Zen ltk module so
let's go ahead and scroll on down here
and we really don't need any more of any
of this
will comment this out for now you might
want to return to it later but actually
I'm gonna get rid of it somebody using
anymore in this tutorial so I get rid
anyway
now what we're going to do is talk about
some named entity recognition so we've
got tagged that still has are parts of
speech and all of that and then what we
can do is we can say named ant for named
entity and that's going to equal n LT KN
e chunk and then we want to chunk by a
named entity tag and then we can do
named aunt dot draw now let's save and
run that close this okay so here you can
see part of what is causing some problem
immediately
we've got White House so facility white
organization house person Eric but not
catching Draper but I think it doesn't
catch Draper in this instance possibly
because there's no space between this
these words anyway continuing along no
named entities found okay served America
found that at least thank you and forego
any further I probably should um show
you guys what these words even mean so
here are I'll just paste them right in
here these are named entity type
examples so you have an organization a
person location date time money percent
facility GPE this is geographical kind
of location issue so this would be a
location but this is more like a general
location
uh so anyways those are the types let's
go back over to what we're showing up
here no named entities there none there
woops misclicked
come on give us another one drop in nuts
okay our union is strong okay so that
was a correct grab there uh
so let's close this though let's go here
close this okay
and what you can also do though if you
don't care it'll still pick these up but
if you don't care about these very
specifically what you can do is you can
say this and then binary equals true and
what this does for you is it just
classifies everything as a named entity
period it doesn't actually tell you like
any like organization look person
location anything like that cuz like I
said sometimes it's just inaccurate
unexpected indent what have we done
it's probably just angry at this I don't
know see anything else that should give
me unexpected in them yeah okay
so here you can see that the named
entity chunk was correct at least in
this instance - chunk Whitehouse
together okay so that was good it
probably got Eric Draper if that space
wasn't an issue but anyway it's finding
these named entities now like we had a
few to go before we found any more named
entities so I just want to kind of X out
a few applause I don't think we've made
it past that I can't remember shoot
let's click again
hmm we're not really seeing anymore
I can't believe we're not funny see if
we can find a named entity protect our
people maybe people should have been
warned
oh we found some though your United
States is named entity and so on so any
guys good enough we'll close this out
and uh let's go back one more time to
the original version so if we look we'll
see here that these are separated when
you did without binary okay so remember
this would be before it was binary
equals true this one to take out the
trash someone do that for me a facility
organization so it's it's calling white
and house separate right they're not
actually being called the exact same
like they're not part of the same entity
as opposed to when we called this to be
binary true you'll find that they were
not separate see they are part of the
exact same I figure out I get that
little tag that you should like that
get rid of it whatever jerk there we go
got it uh anyway this classifying them
is the same named entity so it might be
useful for some of you if you are hoping
to get those together
same thing with Eric Draper if that
space wasn't there it would pick it up
but I think if it wasn't binary outfit
yeah if it wasn't binary it would
probably say stew anyway it can get kind
of annoying so ltk is named entity
recognition can be really useful but
it's like false positives or kind of
high and it's error rate is also kind of
high so you'd want to have something
else in place to maybe check the name
than any recognition but you know that's
it for the basics of the named entity
recognition it's actually pretty useful
to have but I've sometimes I go back and
forth sometimes I'll use the names and
any recognition but sometimes I'll just
look for nouns and that almost worse
just as good so anyway that's that you
can also combine the two though keep
that in mind
so if you find if you use named entity
recognition you can search for all nouns
and then also if you find a named entity
that has two named entities back-to-back
chances are they actually should go
together
why n ltk doesn't have that kind of
understood I don't really know that I'm
sure the people that are much smarter
than me and so I'm sure there's a really
good reason why but anyway that works
for me at least so maybe if you're
looking for something specific like that
you might want to try that out so that's
it for the named entity recognition if
you have any questions or comments
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
things for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time